exchange use with regard to the eurasian
integration
cooperation in the caspian region they
will also exchange assessments from the
station in the central asia in the
context of security risks particularly
stemming from instability in afghanistan
and the activities of radical and
extremist organizations
near the region after that on april 12th
sergio lavrov will visit
uh egypt he will hold talks with the
president
and his egyptian counterpart they will
discuss prospects for the further
development of bilateral cooperation
in political trade economic cultural
humanitarian and other spheres as well
as a situation in middle east and
northern africa
russia attaches great importance to
maintaining high level
cooperation with egypt which is one of
the key partners in middle
east and northern africa our relations
are based on
friendship respect and mutual
consideration of interests
in cairo's sergey lavrov will also match
with the
secretary general of the league of arab
states ahmed albergate
upon the invitation of the foreign
minister of iran
sergey lavrov will visit tehran on april
13th
ministers will discuss the entire range
of bilateral agenda
first of all they will discuss its trade
and economic elements in the context of
implementing
key joint projects in power energy and
transport
as well as they will discuss prospects
for strengthening cultural and
humanitarian ties between russia and
iran and their cooperation in fighting
the pandemic
they will also exchange views on the
pressing issues of international agenda
including the situation around the joint
comprehensive plan of action
and the situation in syria afghanistan
yemen and the persian gulf
and now i will move to our
agenda tomorrow
on april 2nd we will celebrate
the day of unity between the peoples of
russia and belarus
that day 25 years ago the two countries
have signed the treaty on the union
between belarus and russia which has
become the
which has become the first steps towards
signing
the treaty on the creation of the union
state in 1999
these documents set forth guidelines for
the further russia belarus corporation
based on the common history and the
friendship between
the brotherly peoples of russia and
belarus
25 years ago our countries have decided
to establish
politically and economically integrated
union in order to join their material
and intellectual potential so to boost
their economy to create
equal conditions to raise living
standards
and spiritual development which is
i remind you i'm talking about the
article 1 of the
treaty signed in 1996. we've made
successful progress in building the
union state
and so many things entered the daily
life and we feel their
facts in our daily life
i'm talking about the equal rights of
russian and belarus citizens in
healthcare their social and pension
system
education freedom of travel place of
residence and employment
our countries are effectively
implementing the
important joint endeavors in trade
economic
defense humanitarian scientific and
technical and other space and
international stage we implement
initiatives that are important for the
sustainable development of russia and
belarus as well as for
the global community and together we
are dealing with common challenges and
threats together we are ready to work
with our belarus
friends of the entire range of bilateral
agenda into interests of
ensuring the stable development of
russia
and belarus as you know
on march 25th
the ice-affiliated terrorist group of
more than 100
terrorists has perpetrated an armed
attack
in palma and the northern province of
the republic of mozambique
as a result of their criminal acts
dozens of people were killed including
foreigners that worked at the gas field
we receive reports about the person gone
missing and according to
the russian embassy uh there are no
victims among russian
citizens as for march 30s the armed
forces of mozambique and the national
police
managed to take back control of the city
but still we hear reports about the
sporadic terrorist attacks that take
place in cabo delgado
and as in general the station is begin
stable
and we strongly condemn this atrocity
and
wish prompt recovery and express
our profound condolences today would
like to point your attention to the fact
that today
we have released an interview of sergey
lavrov
in the tv program which i great game in
english
you can find the video on the official
website of the foreign ministry
in this interview sergey lavrov is
talking about
today's realities and
our cooperation with
key world actors
this conversation was quite heated and
interesting
and this conversation determines the
current status of international affairs
but i would like to point your attention
to the fact
that where start we'll start
talking about um our relations with the
united states it's not about the
bilateral agenda well we're going to
discuss some aspects of that
but i would like to discuss some
problematic issues
recently we have seen that the
usda department has published the
country reports on human rights
practices
we believe that such reports published
by the united states
should be published about the human
recitation
in the united states itself but they
prefer to focus on the station in other
states
this is a lengthy document but
largely it's an empty document so
it's it's also just a dedicated station
in our country
but it leaves a strong impression of a
deja vu
the text is full of double standards
in terms of assessing the situation with
human rights in different states
these states are cynically divided into
good and bad ones
depending on whether they adhere to
strategic guidelines of the united
states
so we see some countries at fault and we
see
a number of cliched claims and it's
quite easy to
predict uh what are they without even
reading the report
we can't help but be ironic but about
the
u.s administration statement that they
will counter
the human rights violations wherever
they occurred
regardless of the fact if perpetrators
of these violations our partners or
opponents of the united states again
the united states
said that they will counter human rights
violations wherever they occur
i believe that first of all
they should work with your own
authorities and bodies like
pentagon like other military agencies
because
they carry out so many things all over
the world which lead
to cynical human rights violations i'm
going to talk about that in greater
detail later
we have noticed that the chinese state
council has
released the report on human rights
violations in the united states in 2020
it's a real document it doesn't have any
cliches
it provides objective facts they show
that the situation in the united states
has spiraled out of control
the situation was aggravated by such
factors as
the coronavirus sprayed political
turmoil inter-ethnic conflict social
division
it's interesting to note that
the united states haven't carried out
such reports with regard to
their human rights association but
when there is a need they talk about the
social division about human rights
violations but at the same time
they don't discuss it at the
international level i don't know why
they don't do that
it's just interesting to watch them the
chinese document also mentioned
the fact that people's confidence in the
american electoral system
dropped to the lowest level in 20 years
however based on washington's reaction
the megalomania when
is getting stronger when we are talking
about the respect for human rights
standards
we have repeatedly noted that the united
states and their allies
more arrogantly more actively more
blatantly intervened into domestic
affairs of other states we will discuss
it later again
and as sergey lavrov
pointed out in his interview that the
united states as well as
the west have forgotten how to use
the classic diplomacy but instead these
sanctions at their major instrument
they promote
their ideologically driven agenda
which is aimed at
maintaining their dominance by hindering
the development of other countries
and i need to say that they impose
sanctions illegal sanctions that have
nothing to do with reality
these sanctions targets uh
human rights well it's this is abstract
but it is an important element of
today's
american foreign policy to help
washington to have a more objective
perception of the human rights situation
in the world we
offer them to learn about the
human rights situation in their own
country that was published by
the russian foreign ministry you can
find so many interesting facts there
and again we call on washington to start
working with their own mistakes instead
of imposing their double standards and
mentorship
and now let's discuss some details
what am i talking about when i'm talking
about the fact that there are
some things that take place in the
united states that are more important
than
human rights violations actually i'm
talking about
uh the migration crisis
today the migration crisis at
the mexican border is becoming a
humanitarian
emergency so it requires the attention
of
international structures like the united
nations human rights ngos
and all those who are indifferent to
suffering of children
caught in inhumane conditions
the reality is shocking in deportation
isolation
cells that are overcrowded and were not
designed for
long stay imagine how many people are
there
that is about 18 000
miners there are not enough resources
and means for that is
adequate accommodation close to some
human conditions
children were pushed into open
air cages where there are inadequate
sanitary norms spreading coronavirus and
they have to sleep
on the floor again i would like to
highlight that is
not 18 people though
we know that every life is important in
the us it's not one
thousand eight hundred it is eighteen
thousand their ch their parents
storm the southern borders of the us
the number of detainees exceeds hundreds
of thousands
every day the u.s border is crossed by
thousands of people
in february march the country was
penetrated by about 50 000
illegal people and migrants among them
many drug traffickers and criminals
the law enforcement board is believed
that by the end of the year the number
of
refugees in the border territory would
reach 1 million people we believe that
washington should
treat the miners in a different way
otherwise this
is a flagrant violation of its
international human rights
obligations we are talking about article
6 freedom
from torture right to life and
u.n convention against torture and other
cruel inhuman or degree
degrading treatment or punishment
the conditions of the detention
can be considered as torture and inhuman
treatment and this situation demands
attention
of certain international monitoring
mechanisms
that is the human rights committee and a
committee against
torture we hope that the us
media would turn its attention to this
topic
not just attentively not also
impartially but would make it a central
topic we know that
the civil society in the u.s is always
concerned by the human rights
and its compliance in other countries we
are hopeful
that the freedom of expression in the us
would serve a noble cause
so the interests of the u.s people i
understand
that this topic
is something that doesn't concern the
state department that much
it's not the navalny case of course
because uh
every briefing that they have is
about him but maybe 18 000
miners is something that is worth their
attention
i'll remind that the us is the only
state
in the world that has not become a party
to the
convention on children's right and this
is a universal
instrument in the area of children
rights and there are also two
major agreements in the migration area
that is the
global convent on the refuges and the
global
agreement on a safe and legal migration
the new administration
opened the pandara box with its games
around traditionally thorny migration
topic
the humanitarian crisis that is
rampaging
in the u.s and that is one of the
democratic values police and human
rights police
shows again that the pre-election
campaign aimed at vested
and narrow interests now shows that they
are quite indifferent to
human sufferings
so children become hostage hostages to
their
domestic affairs and this is disgraceful
again 18 000 miners
now what we were supposed to discuss
long ago we mentioned that
once we skimmed through this but now
it's high time
we talk about it and the u.s forced us
to do that and the
current administration as well so we
need to touch upon a favorite topic
that is the interference of the u.s into
affairs of other states in fact this is
a politically correct
topic that does not reflect the essence
of the issue it's not just an
interference not just meddling or
washington
into various affairs of other states at
different stages
this is the blood that covers hands of
the u.s
administration let's start so we've
already touched upon the topic
of the u.s med link into other affairs
of other states
obviously in majority of the cases
this coincided with the cold war era
but even today
they have something to think about
the ideological rivals on the
international arena tried
to acclaim their political positions and
they tried
to position their government and they
said that country after the end of the
second
world war europe with its block division
has become an arena of actions
and then other states in asia africa and
latin america were the
theater of the actions the political
mode
often intertwined with economic
interests they wanted to take control
over transport corridors
natural resources oil and gas
all of this was covered disguised under
a good
course that is fighting
for the democracy human rights situation
again that
is security issues
restraining mechanisms such as the unit
has not always been efficient
as a barrier for the white house to
redraw the political map of the world of
course i'm not going to turn this
briefing into
a historical lecture but at the same
time i want to remind
you about some of the effects of the u.s
medic in the last decades and what it
led to
september 11 1973 with the direct
support of the u.s in
chile there was a military coup that
also the democratically
elected president salvador allende which
established the
dictatorship of augusto pinochet that
lasted
17 years and well maybe you've forgotten
that in
the u.s but it was fraught with a
deep split in the chilean society
we also remember activities of the
american special forces that
helped the military government to
be in office in guatemala in 1982
afterwards there was 1983 military
intervention in grenada they also
financed
the anti-government militia nicaragua in
1984.
they openly meddled into the
domestic affairs of these states which
has been
confirmed by the ruling of the
international court of justice in the
hague
in 1986 within the iran contrast
case in 1989
we saw the military intervention of the
years in panama
one of the reasons is the
non-obedience of the years to fulfill
with its own
agreement over the control and the
panama canal
indeed why president manuel noriega was
captured
and he cooperated tightly with the
cia starting with 50s he
supplied all the
illegal weapons military equipment and
money noriaga was extradited to the u.s
and sentenced for record trafficking of
drugs
and money laundry for 17
40 years but he spent only 17 years
in the u.s during the intervention in
panama
several thousand people died after the
invasion
15 u.n security council member states
condemned the u.s intervention in panama
but there was a veto
in to block the resolution the
organization of american states
also condemned the intervention of the
u.s
a flagrant example of the same kind of
interventionist
behavior of the us on the international
arena
is cuba for over 60 years the population
of cuba
advocates its own way of development
fighting against direct attacks of
washington against its sovereignty
the grant and symbol
was the cuban missile
crisis in 1961 the bay of pig's
invasions
these economic aggression as well that
was condemned
repeatedly by the international
community including from the un
general assembly restroom did not
prevent
the anti-cuba blockade and the
multiple sanctions against
havana including the toricella act of
as well as hamsburton law of 1996
and many others
this is an unfavorite game
and double standards because the
cuban island was designated
as a country that supports terrorism
this cynical intervention of the u.s is
also
exemplified in venezuela for many years
they tried
to suffocate the economy of venezuela
through
sanctions we see that they incited for
national
armed forces to start a
military coup in 1992 in angola the u.s
financed
its own candidate for presidential
elections
jonas savimbi however
he lost before and after the elections
they helped him military to fight
legitimate government following conflict
about 650 000 people died the official
reason for the support of the militia is
fighting communist government in 2002
the u.s received the benefits for its
own
companies mr savimbe was not desired
anymore
the us demanded he stops military
actions
he refused and now the quote of an
american diplomat
the problem with the muppets is that
they do not always
respond when you pull the strings
as a result of clashes mr savimbi was
killed in 1998 in all shifa
plant in sudan terrorist osama bin laden
ordered the manufacturing of chemical
weapons what did they do then
of course they used cruise missiles
against these
plants which turned to be just a
pharmaceutical plant
that only produced medicine against
malaria
in sudan it manufactured 90 percent
of the medicine in the country and as a
result
of this missile was the death of
tens of thousands of people because they
didn't have medicine to get their
treatment
the results of the journal's
investigation of new york times in 1999
confirmed that the decision to deliver a
blow
against the plant was taken without
any grounds and the leadership of the
state department
forced the secretary general assistant
to destroy the report
of the analyst that said that it was not
advisable to
destroy the pharmaceutical blunt plant
as for the balkans
we mentioned that a lot including during
the last breathing
so without dwelling
on the details you know the horrible
details the u.s
wanted to
make the political regime there as loyal
as possible they
used a toolbox
that was a kind of a pattern to
impose political will of washington
and its allies in other parts of europe
they tried to turn yugoslavia into a
fertile ground
and send the
[Music]
there were existing agreements after the
dayton
peace agreement on bosnia and
herzegovina in 1995 from within they
stimulated
the creation of oppositional forces as a
result after
unclear result of the electoral campaign
under the pressure on the part of the
united states and european
countries after street protests
milosevic was forced to
to be deposed
another example iraq 2003
official casa's belly to for the united
states invade this country after the u.n
sanction
i will point out they cited the
connections between saddam hussein
regime within international
terrorism and the alleged cia
information on the existence of
weapons of mass destruction existence in
iraq without any confirmation later
as colin powers demonstrated
uh alleged evidence of the existence of
those weapons
iraq was captured by american american
forces and the saddam hussein was
captured as well and was executed later
the united states brought the government
into power which consisted
of loyal followers of united states
strategic interests
there has been documents confirming that
the total number of victims of this
of this whole situation among the
civilian population number of victims
since
up to 2011 when the american forces were
drawn
was from 100 000 to 300 thousand people
once again i'm talking about documents
clearly
confirming this according to the ngos
libya 2011 at the united nations
security council by its resolution 1973
sanctioned military interference in to
libya
under the pretext of defending civilian
population as a result of
libyan governments suppressing military
positions this gave
nato an opportunity to
conduct aerial operations against the
regime who has been in power
for more than 40 years as a result of
the civil war the leader of
syria muammar qaddafi was
deposed and killed in october 2011.
according to the daily telegraph more
than 20 000 people
including civilians were killed on both
sides of the conflict
what about the number of refugees
according to provisional data we are
talking about
tens or hundreds of thousands of people
according to the un
report of
2012 the negative effect of the leave
increases
crisis was experienced by
all the countries in the sahel region
algier
chad egypt mali mauritania niger
and tunis i would like to say
that when american colleagues
consider it possible to
suspect somebody or something or to
accuse somebody of something they should
consider their own history first
and to remember their own history they
don't even need
to read books it's really difficult you
know
they should just wash and watch their
hands
but there are good news after all in
washington
one of the first decisions in the
political decision taken by the biden
administration in january this year
was the return of the washington 2-d
paris agreement
we are talking about the climate problem
this step demonstrated the intent
of the american administration not only
to speed up the transition of the
country to the ecological rails
but only but also the attempt to be at
the head of the world
environmental movement
several months before the return of the
united states to the paris agreement
on the 4th november 2020 united states
officially withdrew from that agreement
we think that the paris agreement
is a solid international legal base
for long-term climate settlement we hope
that in the future washington's police
industry will be more predictable
and not fraught with uh political
interests
russian federation pays grant attention
to
the the protection of the environment we
are actively participating in
international processes
in ecological sphere and we also
contributing much
to form global environmental protection
mechanism we are
standing for de-politicized and
responsible
approach to the problem of the global
climate change
we consider that any state can choose
the optimal model of the green
transformation depending on the national
conditions
we think that the problematic of the
climate change
is one of the areas where russia and the
united states approaches
could be similar or
quite close we once
we have on numerous occasions said that
it is possible
to surpass the climate
challenges only through cooperation
another topic linked to human rights
this is all linked to united states we
have noted
information the foreign media on the
appointment
of the special reputation
human rights council on extrajudicial
executions agnes kalimar as its sector
general of a famous
human rights ngo amnesty international
we would like to wish her
successes on hero on her new post and
we hope that she will not be guided by
the interest of a select group of states
but rather by objective facts
and the desires of the public russian
federation
always thought that the questions of
appointing new experts on the
post of the special procedures on the
hrc
should be politicized and do not demand
a special reaction from
countries but recently we see a trend
where international human rights ngos
and monitoring mechanisms of
international organs
on human rights are functioning
as a common system expert in human
rights just
simply transfer from one position to
another
one of the principal supplier
of
specialists for structural agencies of
the un secretariat
is correct amnesty international and
other
not influential international ngos
one of the previous leaders of feminist
international irene khan
is currently the hrc special reporter
on the freedom of opinion but they're
also reverse process currently
and the kalia mars appointment is a
telling example of that
we have a question this regard what kind
of objectiveness we can talk about
when estimating the human rights
situation in select states if
hrc special rapporteurs are selected
among professional critics
of state structures
from among the representatives of civil
society unfortunately
we see facts of pressure or
influence against such organizations we
can see the situation as problematic
and demanding close attention and
discussion in intergovernmental forms
another statement
topic will be once again linked
linked to the problem of the collective
west attitude towards human rights
i can't say that it's surprising but oh
well
made us even smile a bit
alexander younger former secretary
general general select director general
of the secret intelligence of
united kingdom and the former head of
mi6 said that their goal was to
force russia to come to a decision that
whatever prophets they would wanted to
reap from their actions
in the end they wouldn't be wouldn't be
worth it
and they would do it according to their
rules and according to their laws and
values
and they would be victorious in the end
i won russia and any other states
intending
to undermine our way of life
i would like to warn them against
underestimating
our goal-orientedness and our
possibilities and possibilities of
our allies
we see a lot of people talking about the
so-called values
but we didn't expect of course that the
representatives mi6 would be one would
be the ones
speaking about it now we understand
where such values are formed in the
united kingdom
i would like to understand what exactly
is he talking about
we have heard a lot about these values
that they're so eagerly defending
of such values they are just steaming
ahead
let's see
does the torture and other violations of
human rights figure among those
values because we saw the examples that
during counterterrorist operations in
other countries
killings by british servicemen of
civilians
in afghanistan are those those values
that you defend so legally
lies about the wmds in iraq
incorrect intelligence that tony blair
had to apologize for
the deaths of hundreds of thousands
civilians
were worth just a simple apology there
were no material compensation no
political outcome
i'm not talking about accountability
this was a state
that was one of the leaders of the
unlawful
criminal operation in iraq is this also
one of your values
the iraq dossier of wikileaks testifying
of
mass crimes against civilians on the
part of british servicemen
is it also value do defend that as well
will the united kingdom justice system
fight against the problem that dozens of
fraudsters among russian citizens are
just
living their best life united kingdom
recently
we saw that the british finished census
has become
a laundry room for criminal proceeds for
money
extorted not from only from russia but
from other countries
do you defend those values too
now on the british values in the
historical
context the crimes
there have been loads of materials about
the united kingdom's crimes during the
colonial era we've
already touched upon this topic in 2018
but we will
be publishing our materials after the
briefing
on our website maybe mr young
meant the freedom of speeches of value
but
but really maybe let's let's see about
the situation
that there are facts justifying that
freedom of speech is not really
respected in his homeland there is it's
been
systemically used for political gain
the violation of the principles of
freedom of speech and pluralism of media
is just a normal practice united kingdom
during the february 26
briefing were just said that
the russian media faced outright
discrimination during the global
conference on the freedom of the media
which was happening in london in july
russian media representative were not
allowed to attend the conference
due to the publication of the so-called
british file
which testified that british government
was sponsoring some bloggers working
in russia
we also seen we also have some proofs
that
they were engaging in regime-changing
activities
in russian territory they were trying to
undermine
the russian influence abroad
russia english media are participating
inspiration and
also conducting pr campaigns
so what association with the key
strategic partner of the united
kingdom whose attention london
listens attentively what's going on with
their
tandem if we are going to
talk about it and rule the terms one
briefing is not enough it will take
several years
i'm talking about the electoral
electoral process of the country
that likes to lecture others about the
respect for human rights and electoral
standards
but what about the fact that the half of
americans
and this is the information provided by
american structures companies
organizations
what about those americans half of the
american population
who doubt about the transparency
legitimacy of these elections
the recent elections
and those who disagree um
because they basically views on what
they read what they see
people they believe that the elections
were stolen
they are prosecuted
they are expelled from social media they
are declared as domestic terrorists they
are facing with criminal charges
this is this is the value that we
should all defend so these are the
western values
that you're talking about
then i can say that the british society
itself
is skeptic about it if you
just judging by what we see and what we
read
western values we have to pose a
question what are these values
but just we want to understand uh what
they are
defending zealously so talking about the
freedom of speech in great britain
we noticed that the department of
education of great britain
the department of dedication has decided
to
create a position of this free speech
and academic freedom champion
so what's it about first i was thinking
that it was some kind of a special
representative or special rapporteur
no it's not
in great britain there is a problem
there is a collapse with the freedom
of speech so this person
the british government
freedom of speech violations in
universities and student unions
and they will find those organizations
that restrict
the academic staff and students and
their
free speech and
scientific and in choosing their
scientific directions
so this champion will review questions
related with the dismissal of academic
staff
with regard to the situation this
decision is presented as the
government's response to the growing
request from academic staff and expert
community
which requires to tame the prosperous
leftist intellectual culture which have
taken aggressive forms
of war culture and council culture this
deplorable situation with the freedom of
speech and
british universities is confirmed by the
results of the social
studies according to the cevitas
institute for the study of civil society
35 of british universities are in the
red zone
51 are in the yellow zone and only 14
percent of british universities have no
syndrome
censorship at all so in general we have
to know
that the active cultivation of this now
liberal
values someone
doesn't call them anything but we see
that
the active cultivation of now no liberal
values in
great britain is starting to bring its
own effects
which perplexes representatives of their
own establishment
well we have hopes that finally london
started
to deal with their own issues they
understood the gravity of the problem
so we'll see the result of their actions
on the other hand what
prime minister wants from british
universities
if they see how
the british government treats the
freedom of speech i'm talking about
assange case who was prosecuted for
political reasons no one
favors his journalist activities
everyone sees how the freedom of speech
is manipulated
how deployed media is managed by
the british political establishment what
do they want from the academic staff and
students
if it's the government who plays a major
role here
so again sanctions we see that
canada has hit russia with the new
sanctions that are related to crimea
we have commented that but we have
received questions
it shows uh the obstinance of official
canadian authorities
in rejecting the objective reality
the treatment is a single one you have
to forget about
your illusions because the residents of
crimea have already voted
and they cannot abandon their historic
choice
and any attempts to dictate canadian
to dictate by canadian authorities how
sovereign countries should live
on only undermine the canadian
reputation and they put it
into the confrontation with the growing
number of international
actors russia won't leave this sanctions
without
proper response and we believe that in
this context china made a justified
decision by imposing sanctions against
canadian
officials and structures for
interfering into domestic affairs of
china is just ridiculous
by western mainstream particularly
australia
has imposed the sanctions
because it's just satirical
they australian post sanctions because
they
found out in 2021 about the
church bridge i understand that
australia is
far away from us but today you have mass
media mass communications social media
messengers just
it took them several years to find out
about the bridge
it's just too funny
it's not surprise it's a surprise for us
because they have been following the
statement made by kiev that there
wouldn't be any breach
and now they see that there is a breach
and they understood that it exists
it's not the last uh fake news published
by kiev
after the response of the ministry's
representative office in central we
noted
the video fake published by ukrainian
propagandists
on march 25th the official ukrainian
twitter channel twitter account
published a two-minute
video about the history of china it had
moments that had nothing to do with the
history
of crimea the propaganda machine is
making the same mistakes again earlier
they used in their materials about
the tragedy of crimean tatars they used
the photo
with the hitlerites ascending
jews from the occupied poland to
extermination camps
in 2019 the same mistake was made
by the ukrainian embassy in washington
and after that in 2020 the permanent
representative of the united states and
osce
made the same mistake it's like an
infection it spreads
too quickly and that time the key of
colleagues
excelled themselves and this
they have shown a photo from the
american archives of the memorial museum
of
holocaust and they actually provided an
explanation that this is a deportation
carried out by the stalin regime and
after that
after we revealed that this is a
historic falsification
after it appeared in mass media
the authors deleted the video despite
all the fact that all the materials that
we provide despite all the consultations
we hold they continue to do that
and talking about the sanctions
joseph burrell the high representative
for uh foreign policy
and security
that several non-eu countries
joined the new and russian sanctions
that were invented
by the european union based on the
novellas case remarkably the number of
countries
whose unfriendly behavior is no surprise
to us
include northern macedonia and
montenegro
both scorpio and podgorica assure us
that they want to
develop and to strengthen normal
relations with russia and as for
montenegro they want to restore
them after the many years of degradation
they talk about their willingness
to create all the necessary conditions
for that but at the same time they're
trying
to explain why they had to be in the
uh to be in the wake of their isophobic
western
uh policy before they refer to
the false imperative for those who want
to join the european union to
stick to the foreign political decisions
and directives
but in other words they mechanically
supported staffs without being involved
in their development
we closely follow their attempts of
north macedonia and montenegro
to show edges of their policy with
regard to russia unfortunately
their sanctioned solidarity shown by
scorpion pogoritza
only shows the inconsistency and
dependence
of our balkan colleagues we remain open
for the open
equitable dialect based on the mutual
respect and
mutual consideration of interest their
consumerism and clumsy maneuvering
to
deal with the opportunistic objectives
for the sake of uh
alliance with third countries only
undermine our confidence and
don't stimulate the development of
bilateral relations with russia
and now i'll say a few words about
lithuania
we are appalled by
the
by first verdict of the lithuanian court
of appeal on the fabricated case on the
events of january 13th 1991
which say that the former soviet
soldiers party members and public
officials
were sent long sentenced to long terms
in prison
and they were charged with
crimes that they haven't committed and
as for the russian citizens hearing mel
and gennady
ivanov their sentence was tightened up
so what is the western position
to the situation in lithuania and their
unwillingness to find the
real perpetrators this is the show
tribal
shameful show tribal that takes place in
lithuania
lithuania that actively fight for the
respect of human rights in neighboring
countries on their own territory
that they see as the space for democracy
um lithuanian authorities think that
they
can act with impunity
and they can manipulate justice
cynically and blatantly for their
political goals
we express strong protest about the
consultation with yuri mal who has been
languishing
in prison for seven years and he will
have to spend the another three years
and we will
[Music]
help his lawyers to appeal to the
supreme court
and will help them to contact
international judicial authorities
and we will pay attention to the
unbearable prison conditions
for the person who suffers from the
acute chronic disease maybe we will see
any comments maybe we will see any
international conferences
about maybe we would see protests
all over the world that cares about
human rights
well we'll see what happens next
we require from lithuania to release
immediately
wrongly convicted russian citizen yuri
mel
and criminal actions of wellness won't
be left without consequences
and another topic on april 4th
on april 4th the republic of senegal is
going to celebrate its 61st anniversary
of independence
it went through hard times of colonial
dependence and slavery in 1444 the
portuguese were the first ones
to land there close to the senegal river
later it was controlled by the dutch
english and then
the french in mid 17th century
senegal turned into a base for
colonization of west africa and the
gorilla island became a regional center
of slave trade
the independence movement in senegal
started in 1914 to 1918.
in 1948 national political unions were
formed
and in 1956 the
senegal democratic bloc was established
headed by leopold sengoh
the future first president
of the country in 1960 april 4th
senegal declared its independence
the modern senegal is a dynamically
developing
state that plays an important role in
african and international affairs
in 2022 dakar is going to chair the
african union the russian senegalese
relations are
sustainably friendly they develop
all the time senegal in the last year
has become
our major trade and economic partner
in west africa and we do our best to
develop our bilateral interaction we
hope that
our toys would continue deepening to
serve the interests of both our states
we
wish senegal every success and
congratulate it
again and to conclude the
preliminary remarks i would like to
state
that the coronavirus
infection is still spreading
in a concerning manner
the number of confirmed cases is almost
139 million people
the death toll exceeded 2.8 million
people
that is the global statistics
against the backdrop of this alarming
situation we ask our
russian citizens going abroad to
be cautious as you know the
operative stuff
restored connection with sri lanka
afghanistan uzbekistan
armenia azerbaijan belarus egypt cuba
uae and other countries
and starting with the beginning of the
month it would be allowed
to
travel from bannol belgrade volgagrad
veronica lugolipus canal czech serrat of
sochi to
men south sokolinsk but with all the
measures in place
given that any trip abroad
is fraught with direct risks
to health we ask our citizens to be very
cautious in planning a travel in case
there is an emergency and one needs to
go abroad we
advise you to peruse
information published
on the foreign minister's web page
embassy's web page no doubt
you also need to read the information of
other ministries and bodies
as well as the operative stuff and to
follow all the rules and measures
in place in your countries of
destination
or transit now i stand ready to answer
your questions
what about bulgaria news front
yes good afternoon mary vladimir
if you love i have three questions first
has to do with the statement of the
representative of the
eu on international affairs
jose verrell who said
in his accusation that russia is hostile
he says that russia acts against
the eu and tries to
meddle into its domestic affairs that
it's against democratic values
and they believe that russia and china
again tried to meddle
and in its um in his statement joseph
burrell
singled out a hostile nature of
strategic intentions of russia and china
and they
called for a european strategic
independence
what does the foreign minister make of
this statement
in particular these accusations of being
hostile
in these statements and in their
political
course and their policies they try to
turn things
upside down it is the eu
that through its recent statements and
illegitimate sanctions
against russia and china
continue their hostile policies
they alienate ourselves from the
neighbors on the eurasian continent and
they
get back into their diplomatic
vocabulary
phrases from the cold war era and they
also promote the arc
block thinking the eu also deepens the
division lines attempts of the eu to
talk
to others from the position of power is
quite
dangerous because it can destabilize the
international
relations continuing in the same spirit
the eu risks to be left on the fringes
of the
global economic development that shifts
towards asia
unlike the eu and the usa
our countries russia and china are not
friends against someone
our relations are not sensitive to the
fluctuations of the
environment we stand for a truly
democratic
just multipolar world order
in compliance with the fundamental
principles of the un charter
we can attest to this not only through
our
reciprocal statements to these
foolish statements of brussels the
confirmation to this
is the doctrine documents that been
established many years ago this is a
principle this is a principled position
that's been elaborated
declared and used and applied
for many years we believe that
we should play
on an equal footing that is
what is the backbone of
true intentions not what's been
prescribed to us
instead
we always say that we stand ready to
develop our relations with the eu
that we need constructive interaction
but instead we see that they try to make
up new ideology
and new confrontational formulas towards
other countries as for china
they call it a partner a competitor and
a rival
as for russia they believe that
they need counteraction control and
selective
engagement in the same spirit they need
a gradual
proportional and reverse reversible
bulls think of their cooperation with a
turkey
end of quote we believe that such novel
policies
that is in fact a keratin stick approach
are far from an aspiration to build a
dialogue based on mutual respect as it's
happening
between russian china russia and turkey
we call on our colleagues from the eu
to review their approaches attempts to
unite
against russia and china and to
integrate themselves
into the washington policy cannot
help the task of strategic independence
that the eu is aspiring for
i don't think that this says interest of
common people of the
eu who are not interested in paying
from their own pocket for another
confrontational
era in the european and atlantic area
other questions yes the second question
that has to do with the international
role
happening between russia and the czech
republic
and maybe some general european trend
where
russian diplomats are in the center of
attention i'm talking
about the dismantling of a monument
to the soviet martial
corneth in prague and
we hear from the czech republic
accusations
saying that russia is to be blamed for
the deterioration
of relations between the two countries
and one of the tech journalists wrote
that russian there are too many russian
diplomats in the country and they do
nothing to restore relations
they have not achieved anything what
does the
foreign ministry think of it
and what can you tell about this
monument
i'll start with the second part of your
question you quoted a
journalist in the czech republic that
asked a rhetoric
question on whether there are not too
many russian diplomats in prague
i can only say that
these journalists should have asked
whether
there are not too many czech diplomats
in moscow
in fact the number of diplomats is
something that's been agreed by the
parties and then the that's also a
matter of
parity and again you have to be
impartial
and honest with your readers and tell
them
what these trends can lead to if they
become a reality
as for the marshall conif monument you
said that
it is a it is not a scandal it's a
tragedy
a tragedy for the czech republic and
for this western civilization that
boasts of
[Music]
a number of countries continents
organizations and
people
who've fallen victims of their strategy
when people forget about their history
it's a tragedy
when people revise their own history
and even more so is the fact that people
forget
the history of that survival
so it's not a scandal it is a tragedy
again
as for our relations the municipal
authorities
of warsaw decided
to dismantle of prague dismantle the
martial conif monument
which sends in violation of the
bilateral treaty on friendly relations
and cooperation of 1993 which for
saw for the obligations to preserve the
monuments to the russian soldiers and to
provide access to
them
to settle this artificially
made situation in summer last year
russia
initiated bilateral consultations
unfortunately they're yet to take place
mostly because of the pandemic
restrictions but
hopefully we'll find a way to deal with
the future of this monument
well one more question if you allow
it has to do with the
talks on armenian azerbaijan and by the
preservation of the cultural historic
heritage of armenia in the qarabak
territory we see
that there is vandalism and
sacrilege happening to orthodox churches
we believe
we remember that ilham alive told
president putin that the historical
heritage in the nagorno-karabakh
territories would be preserved
but there are effects on the ground on
the total destruction of a
church close to jibril city
and the destruction of kavanaugh church
or the green
chapel in the sushi city
we've seen footages of this sacrilege
can
russia again turn attention of other
co-presidents of the men's group in the
oc
and to launch an investigation into this
and to instruct the azerbaijani
militaries
related to these crimes
our position is that we stand for the
preservation of the
cultural religious heritage indiana
garnet qarabag
and the adjacent territories will refund
the importance of the
unesco missions that has to go there as
soon as possible and
we maintain contacts on each case
with these countries
international life
international life please good afternoon
i have three questions how would you
comment
the media information about the
detention
of an estonian human rights defender
siridenko on the 15th of march
you know i would comment it pretty
similarly to the my estimation of the
actions
regarding the yuri male case the
punitive
justice we're talking about punitive
justice
executed in the baltic region we have
the same evaluation as in the
aforementioned case
we're talking about another episode of
work of fighting against wrong thing
and the search for the russian trail
political pressure against the numerous
representatives of the russian
diaspora a person who was openly
defending interests of national
minorities in estonia including
in the framework of the national forum
is persecuted for his active civil
position
it's a question towards all heads of
states
of the european union and it also
questions to
the international organizations on the
human rights
agenda where are you where's your
reaction where
please provide this one word of reaction
in the media
post a photograph of this person do
something
ask a question about it there's no
reaction currently we call for the
international committee to
watch the
observance of the norms of international
humanitarian law regarding the activist
sergey seredenko arrested in estonia
another question please
president lithuania
recently said that the russian
authorities were neglecting the
territorial integrity of ukraine
how would you evaluate such statements
russian authorities neglect the
territorial integrity
of its neighbors including ukraine
for many years we being a sovereign
state
in sovereign states we were preserving
and keeping the territorial
integrity of ukraine i remind you
i remind the baltic colleagues if we are
talking about
the crimea situation
crimean residents on numerous occasions
made a case for a referendum about their
fate
and affiliation they did it openly they
tried to
they tried numerous times to appeal to
kiev and use legal mechanism
to defend their rights and freedoms
however
you will not find
any word not a single word in
[Music]
on behalf of civil servants diplomats
officials
and other
employees of the russian ministries
regarding the
difficulties neglecting difficulties
that the crimean residents
with the difficulty face you will not
find any statements undermining the
territorial integrity
of ukraine on behalf of those people
but there was a fact of the interference
in intel in the first of ukraine only
part of
western states and maidan is a telling
example there was a coup d'etat
there was anti-constitutional change of
power
as a result of which the corresponding
processes
were launched and accelerated and they
have nothing
to do with our countries
neighbors of the baltic states are
culpable in this
i'll remind you that i will remind of
this i will send reminders to the tutu
those baltic states officials that
united states
were interfering in the political
processes
in ukraine in 2014 they really
implemented them
after modeling them
tens hundreds of foreign experts and
specialists in all
areas of actions we're talking about
intelligence agencies or mercenaries
we're in the territory of ukraine we're
participating and engaging
under the disguise of consultants or
members of the public
they were participating in the
implementation of the change
of power this was an interference
of pouring powers into the internal
affairs of the sovereign states all
those processes happening in 2014
in the territory of ukraine
led to a whole range of events is a
result of the direct interference of
the western countries the united states
and the eu
into the internal affairs of ukraine
let's
not look for
suspects in the countries that
had nothing to do with the situation
that resulted in
from directions and our countries always
stood for
the sovereignty and independence of
ukraine
we respect it
respected it we developed our political
economic communitarian corporations we
are planning to defer the development of
this
of these relations
we used legal means
and diplomatic avenue of interactions
with the sovereign
authorities of ukraine which cannot be
said
about their neighbors
you are mentioning the representative of
lithuania we cannot say the same for
lithuania
and last question if you allow me yes of
course
polish ambassador to russia mr krievsky
said that warsaw was ready for
equal dialogue for with moscow can you
evaluate as a signal to the beginning of
the nobelization of relations with
warsaw
once again please say polish ambassador
to russia
said that warsaw was ready for the equal
dialogue with moscow
yes i understand that yes yes
we are talking about the first interview
of the new
polish ambassador to russia mr krayevsky
it was published in the russian media
with russia we are of course happy about
this intention of the polish
side and we hope that it will be there
their intentions will be confirmed by
actions
to further make the picture realistic
we hope that
we hope that polish actions will be
confirmed
by well the productive productive
interaction with us and
we would be happy about that
let's touch upon the current situation
of our relations
the new polish ambassador links the bad
state of our bilateral relations with
the
general worsening of worship relations
with the west
in the recent years you know in practice
relations with the western countries
and problems of the dialogue between
russia and warsaw began
long ago
[Music]
a polish national campaign of
erasing the so-called
false sense of gratitude from the polish
society
doesn't contribute contribute to the
better betterment of our
relations
polish officials use this historical
policy
to deny the role of the red army in
liberating poland but also
try to
accuse ussr of unleashing the second
world war
on par with germany the mr ambassador
said that
poland respected the memory
of the fallen warriors of the red army
but unfortunately we are often facing
flagrant cases of vandalism regarding
the
soviet memorials in poland in the
framework of the cynical
campaign to demolish monuments to the
warriors of
the red army 446 such monuments been
demolished as of now
and mr ambassador called
russian media statements that larson was
liquidated as
false that's been the case in 2017 a
mausoleum of the warriors of the red
army
was demolished in chanka in 2018 and
the similar monument was demolished
in this situation the resumption of
dialogue in the framework of the group
on difficult questions
arising from the history of russo polish
relations is not really it's not only
difficult but
senseless the mr ambassador
is considering positive the russia
russo polish trade and economic
relations
in the last two years the goods exchange
decreased by 25
and it continues if warsaw's efforts to
limit
inputs from russia and as sanctions
reduces russia
are also not very beneficial for these
corporations
one of the principal factors
bearing the normalization of contacts
with poland
is warsaw's attempt to militarize the
region of the
eastern europe attracting the multi
capabilities of the united states we see
this as a irresponsible approach to the
current system of the military political
stability in europe
risk of violating the current balance
are much higher
than the illusory threats on the part of
russia
we hope that warsaw will
pay attention to our calls to resume the
dialogue based
on the principles of national law and
mutual respect
there are no objective barriers
on the way to normalize reso polish
relations and the current problems could
be settled
given political will political will of
both countries
however we haven't seen
this will on the part of the polish
party
well of course if they want to improve
relations with us we are more than ready
for that
thank you moscow
first questions already said
you've already mentioned separate
meetings between
the foreign minister of russia and
armenia
does the russian mfa see
the possibility to resolve the problems
promatic questions of this settlement
we have these current meetings we are
holding them right now
so there is not you don't have to wait
for much longer you just have to wait
until the publication of the response
because right now we should have these
negotiations going
and the second question in some years
in on thursday will be
29 years since the establishment of
diplomatic relations
between russia and azerbaijan
you said that russia and zebedee have
a great record and a lot of trust based
on mutual respect
and they can achieve mutual profit
2020 was an important year in those
relations so with a three-part site
statement on the nagona karabakh
settlement
how do you evaluate the effectiveness of
the interaction between
with adera bajan in different directions
and what
are your priorities in this interaction
what common challenges do you see can i
just
pause it for a second because we
are just waiting for a big interview
of the deputy foreign minister mr
radenko
dedicated to the 29 years anniversary of
the establishment of diplomatic
relations with azerbaijan
in armenia you'll you'll be given
detailed explanations
maybe you could comment it to yourself
your media your media
is in the center of our intentions
if you if you find that some of your
questions have been answered we'll be
glad to and so you'll catch the
questions later
russia today please good afternoon
thank you for such a detailed briefing
you have a green green wall behind you
i had to leave house
then uh that's why i'm in an unusual
place currently
let me begin from there
[Music]
from a question that our
channel is facing unprecedented pressure
nevertheless lafayette's authorities
as you probably heard tried to block our
website in russian
youtube has already blocked our
channel despite the fact that we had
three billion views
and you you surely condemned these
[Music]
actions
can we expect anything but a formal
accusation or condemnation
can we implement our rights
yeah i'm aware of the situation as you
know
but talking about what you have just
said
talking about the actions taken by
veteran authorities well it's it's the
question of values
when they are trying to say that we are
trying to spread our influence
destructive influence as they say
on the western values it's about the
values themselves
this is the question i
have to say that on march 31st the
national council of latvia and
electronic media blocked
rt channel in russian and tv ntv ru
ruse24ru until the days net through this
um resources you could have watched
russian tv channels in the internet and
all this
channels and websites have been
blacklisted
it's not in use for us
it's a politically engaged and illegal
attitude of baltic states to russian
media this is the first case
when not the broadcasting is
banned but you cannot even visit the
website
and that very fast to its own
local law on electronic media which says
that the illegal
broadcasting of programs whose content
might
violate laws intellectual intellectual
property
might have negative impact and
might be targeted against
latvia and its citizens well it's fake
it's lies
this we're talking about false
explanations because it has
nothing to do with the real situation
it's just
a pretext to
fight any descent russian descent in
this situation
i know i know about that i just i have
a feeling that
it won't happen with russian mass media
i think that soon in the near future
other countries other mass media
will understand will deal with the same
attitude
talking about values again we're talking
about the cynical violation
of freedom of speech pluralism of media
this tramples on the rights of the
russian-speaking population of latvia
and it means that latvia doesn't fulfill
its commitments
and this um
actions are being continued by with
latvian authorities they target
russian-speaking populations
russian-speaking sources
media and particularly they ban the
right to have
an equal access to information i need to
remind you that
latvia has blocked seven
channels and they on the basis of the
sanctions
targeting dmitry kasilov chief of
russia-swadia russia today uh media
outlet
we call the international community
to monitor the situation and
pay attention to this arrogant
and oppressive policy
you have been asked after question about
the declaration
it's not about declaration but we're
talking about the practical interaction
with international organization what is
the mechanism here
we have to be all aware of the fact that
that russia will also take its uh
protective measures
you've mentioned that youtube blocked
rt arab which had
more than 500 million subscribers had
billions of views
they had no motive to block that so do
you have any guarantees that
it won't be blocked somewhere else no
one has this
guaranteed there is none they
do as they wish i'm talking about
american
major video companies we have to
protect our information space we are
talking about the international legal
framework on which we are working
it's the application of the legal form
quite often there is a situation that we
have laws
that are not quite actively applied so
we're talking about the development of
laws and their active application
and second we're going to develop our
own
platforms and resources yes
i understand very well that
we that when you have so many views and
subscribers and platforms when we're
talking about
hundred thousands hundred millions of
subscribers
and billions of views it's just
difficult
to leave it it's just you don't feel so
well to go to another
platform but there is one thing you have
to keep in mind probably
we won't feel comfortable to go to other
platforms to develop our own resources
and platforms
because we remember how we worked on
previous ones but just at one moment
we will be deprived of an opportunity to
work with
these platforms and we won't have our
own
so i have provided you detailed answer
but i think that these
problems should be settled in these two
directions
and if you allow me i have another
question
and and one clarification
i know that our channel is often accused
of
interfering into electoral processes
that our channel makes attempts to
change the way of life
the thought of people
you have been talking about this and the
briefing you have mentioned it several
times
i think that such attempts
exist in russia i'm talking about
the intentional interference
into domestic affairs of russia this
year we will hold
many elections particular elections to
stay douma and recently
we witnessed quite an interesting event
when the police have taken
uh crack down measures on the
participants of municipal
russia forum it
called the attention of mass media and
international structures
do you think that this attention of
western partners
is a way to
influence russia or is it their
attempt to intervene into domestic
affairs of russia as for the municipal
russia forum
among its coordinators they were ngos
whose activities are recognized as
undesirable in russia
these coordinators have attempted to
carry out a public event
in the violation of the established
sanitary and
epidemiological rules and that's why the
law enforcement
agents responded sometimes
in in the world we see punitive measures
taken by law enforcement agents
not because they violated something but
because they don't agree with the
regulations we see the measures
taken in the netherlands and other
countries so the european union but
they just prefer to care about care
about our situation and they don't think
about what's going on in their countries
but as for the publications
on the crackdown of the forum
these publications are an attempt to
affect the domestic russian processes
actually they are working
on the guidelines provided
in propagandist materials they provide
instructions
to promote marginal opposition in russia
as you remember the washington think
tank
free russia has published the report
in 2019 russia 2030 scenario
after that after that the atlantic
council think tank published
the article russia after putin
all these works are just a collection of
russophobic fantasies
what will happen in russia in the future
and how
you can achieve it such a commissioned
report copy-paste
[Music]
and they are made by people who call
themselves
journalists american journalists do that
it's an element not a single element
it's one of the elements of interfering
into domestic affairs of other countries
we will fight it and how are we going to
do that we're going to
protect our information space and how
we're going to do that i have explained
to you already
and just the clarification what you have
just said today it seems to me that
you have characterized the crisis on the
southern border
of the united states as that it looks
like a
humanitarian emergency the humanitarian
catastrophe
that might have international aspect it
is
it does have an international aspect
because we're talking about
the citizens of a number of states
does the ministry is going to make
is it going to address formally
international structures about
the international catastrophe at the
southern
usborden because we believe it might
have international dimension
and it should be of interest
of human rights experts and those who
are interested in human rights
and those who are dealing with that at
the international scale
oh yes say to you that it's a
humanitarian catastrophe
as for the legal aspects i want to all
on this but
as for the publicity we are used to
calling this a humanitarian catastrophe
imagine 18
000 minus and they are
they did not come of age right
i am talking about miners only and use a
journalist who covers
these issues can imagine the scale of
what's going on
now as for the applications
to give an impetus and to send the
message to international organizations
you don't even need any official
inquiry we believe that this situation
cannot but be part of the attention of
the international community
this is not a remote part of the world
where no
journalists exist and whether there are
no lines of communication
it's the us and mexico we are talking
about and the border between the two
besides journalist
community is supposed to cover this
proactively
and the
foreign ministry gave its assessment
of the situation all of this is
complementary to the work
that international watchdogs are
supposed to perform according to their
mandates
it is for certain their documents that
they are supposed to monitor such
situations
so they are supposed to focus on such
involving 18 000 miners
and that the dire conditions
that they have to put up with so
international organizations and human
rights watchdogs are supposed to
work on this and now we know that the us
diplomats are going
to talk to these international
organizations behind
closed door and try to use all kind of
leverage
to block any criticism
or any
attempts of special envoys and rapidos
as well as human rights watchdogs
to work on their own human rights
problems we all understand this
perfectly so against
this backdrop we are supposed to do our
best
for the us to receive this message from
their partners
closest madness from their strategic
allies
without shying away from their own
problems
you know that you start to solve a
problem by recognizing it
so international organizations ngos are
supposed to recognize the problem
get involved use the
long-standing experience for example
they know how to solve situations
in countries like syria and libya and
they even set up international forum
on the topic they organize
human rights conferences in other
countries
what about organizing
such a conference on the us
maybe others do that not if not the us
itself
don't
the russian compatriots magazine i have
a very long
question all right i'll take a break
after one of the eu foreign ministers
declared this boot
view backs in a russian weapon in a
hybrid
war another eu
president said that this is a new kind
of a war that
means that russia tries to
avail itself of this vaccine to
influence other countries but facts on
the ground show that russia is very
successful
in its combat against the virus
whereas in europe the year viruses
rampaging
so instead of using the positive
experience of russia
they are being on the same titanic
instead of using the russian safety
boats they try to
impede the use of this vaccine
russia and china who are leading
countries in the manufacturing of these
anti-virus
vaccines are declared not a
means of protection but a weapon in this
new war
by the way i recall that during the
first
world war germany started to apply toxic
gases and
france used gas masks that were
manufactured
in russia because back then their task
was to protect people but
now they obstruct their own population
from getting the russian vaccine so
what's their
objective to
[Music]
protect their own people or is it a
different one
so that is as if russia being
well-minded tries to help them but they
see this
as an imposing meddling
can we here address
the people of europe directly because we
are talking about
lives of mirrors of people
as for the russian vaccine many issues
could be explained
when the west tries to shift all kinds
of blames on russia and they
misrepresent
everything we are all
on the same boat and we can defeat the
virus only together
we used to say that tas is entitled
to announce maybe now the foreign
ministry is entitled
to announce and to tell everyone loudly
to tell the truth well that's
partially our mandate and during our
briefings
in our publications and remarks
whether it's the leadership of the
ministry of ambassadors diplomats
the department of information we all try
to
declare truth
okay let's start from the beginning you
say you mentioned the statement of a
number of
western officials on the vaccine
unfortunately even many people in our
country
say oh you just exaggerate i don't
believe that
the well-educated well-read
western politicians
do these kind of macabre things during
the pandemic as
trying to reject that there is a russian
vaccine
and they at the same time cast doubt
on whether the vaccine is efficient
and whether there is and then at the
same time they also accuse russia
of launching a vaccine
war or an aggression expansion
and this goes both for russia and china
but
you wouldn't believe that but that's
true i promise
cue publishing the verb team of these
briefing
statements of heads of
eu organizations
and even some eu leaders
on the matter but for you to
have an understanding how
overtly and illegally
going against their own
mindset these flagships
of the western world use
propaganda and unfavorite competition
as well as political environment
and that is again against the backdrop
of the situation when the whole world
requires
unity in
solving urgent matters that have to do
with life and health
of the global population here for
example
the french president 26th of march
i mean 26th of march 2020 it would be
fine
but this year
we can't put up with it with this this
year
these kind of statements
shocking he said
europe is the only continent that
exports vaccines it is the only
continent of the free world that
has a real strategy and diplomacy
related to the vaccinations here is a
question
if it is the only continent well it's
not true
if we are talking about the fact that
only
europe has a true strategy in the
matters pertaining to vaccines well we
can see how you
implement this in europe your
vaccination is a
ongoing failure it's not us who is
talking about it we just quote your
own citizens your own media
your own doctors and your own state
bodies your own experts okay
you say he says we need to understand
that we are facing
a new kind of war with attempts to
destabilize
the situation and russian china tries to
influence this situation through their
vaccine that's not true we don't want to
use the vaccine as a leverage are you
think
that we don't have a vaccine well we
don't insist on
anything and those
leverages that are financed
by the western countries
and that are supported by brussels half
a year ago
insisted that russia has no vaccine
whatsoever
we heard that we understood that that
your concept that has been imposed on
our citizens as well
does not recognize a new russian vaccine
not even a single one okay if you don't
have a vaccine
and you insisted on it back then and
those who you support politically
insisted on this what kind of war are we
talking about so
do we have a vaccine or do we use a
vaccine
for some objectives but
in fact there is a vaccine not even a
single one but several vaccines
it is efficient and it has never been a
secret that we possess such a vaccine we
never try to monopolize it
and monopolize our development in this
area being a country that was the first
one to
register a vaccine we offered
the world and level playing field
interaction
on a number of avenues pertaining to the
vaccine
that is a joint study exchange of
experience
joint manufacturing and unquestionably
various commercial projects all of them
legal
but you did not heed back then and this
is happening to
the eu quite often we know that
the eu is guided by its senior brother
most of the time this happened when we
told you that we need to unite efforts
to fight the isis some
mocked this offer some were insulted
some got angry but you are
falling in the same trap you reject the
reality you try to
disguise under certain values your own
agenda
and many times it is not just on your
own
agenda but you try to disguise your
inability
to cope with problems of the reality
of the modernity okay same france
the sputnik v vaccine is used
for propaganda and aggressive diplomacy
rather than for medical assistance and
solidarity
what are you talking about we have up
vaccination points we manufacture
vaccines together with the countries
that we're willing to manufacture
this vaccine jointly to use the vaccine
jointly with us
france was uh at some point ready and
then not ready
so why then talk about a propaganda
and an aggressive diplomacy if you
yourself
we're not able or willing to start
interaction with us on the vaccine
then mr borel who is
often coming out with just fantastic
statements
he said on the 29th of december
but still obviously such
a statement testified that
russia intends to test to test its
vaccine during the period of pandemic
and this
is dangerous for the general public
and he immediately transferred to
isis who uses the
connerval situation in it to fulfill its
goal
this is just a nonsensical statement and
the eu
creates new structures to fight
alleged russian propaganda and
defamation
mr braton said that they didn't need
sputnik v
that they they had the possibility
to ship 350 million doses until the end
of year
russia on the other hand had troubles
manufacturing
the vaccine and russian citizens find
difficulty in accessing the product
eu could help russia to manufacture
the vaccine while giving priority to its
citizens
deutsche welle another source
and this paper said uh a
more strict statement but i will not
just
i'll not transcribe it to you right away
and all those people and organizations
they state
that we have some kind of problems and
they wanted to help us but
it's them who have problems they cannot
supply enough vaccines they
cannot really harmonize
the internal risk measures with the
vaccinations
and they just drown in their inability
to counter the problem
and still they and they still
accuse russia of some unexisting
problems
usually the head of the european
commission
said that they still couldn't understand
why russia theoretically
suggested millions of doses when the
progress
of the vaccination among its own
population was still lacking
we offered interactions interaction in
producing millions of doses but they
still didn't
didn't want to cooperate with us
we now understand what we have to expect
from the european colleagues
other countries of the world understood
it too
chairman of the european council michel
said that
they that they didn't they they
shouldn't have
uh let themselves be fooled by russian
efforts
and just see the situation when
they encountered their own problems they
just switched to other topics and don't
mention them
they said that they couldn't trust
russian efforts because
there's still
troubled operations to deliver vaccines
to the public
we have no troubles in delivering
vaccines states and organizations
are applying to us to give them this
vaccine
and we are not imposing our will and
imposing our
vaccines to this to other states
and other states do that at the same
time
our embassies receive
requests or even demands suggestions
offered
to ramp up the capability of interaction
in manufacturing or buying of our
vaccines
what is there to be said hello
chairman of the european agency of
medication
mr and the representative of the
austrian agency of
health
well this is just nonsense
it's shameful to say something like this
[Music]
is repeated to be good but putin doesn't
want to use it as a cure for the russian
people it offers it to the world
as one that's another means of
government warfare
it's uh it's a statement of 5th of
february 2021.
question to mr prime minister please
call your ambassador
and tell him to pick up his phone and go
and
take some pictures of the vaccinations
in russia
we have points of vaccination we have
hospitals and
other points mobile points of
vaccinations
what are you talking about well maybe
our ambassadors
are not giving you enough information
well it's no wonder you are
turning off our channels and blocking
them and you receive admission from the
western media but
we know how efficient they are all
through our embassies
well maybe maybe your embassies are
giving wrong information
they're just copying each other this
flowing nonsense is appalling
gen psyche said that they were tracking
the attempts of
other countries like china and russia to
use vaccines as a means to achieve
success internationally
we don't use vaccines as a political
tool is it
as a cure and no other way if there is
another way to use it
well please state department please tell
us
how to use it
now returning to your questions i just
couldn't
but i just couldn't but state my opinion
on this
information because one while we collect
such statements such nonsense
we are faced with we understand that it
is
being written in a single
informational center center strategy
strategic planning
somewhere deep in the nato then they
spread this information
and i think they check
against delivery later
then the strategic communication
services of the united
eu and nato spread this mission further
to the media
[Music]
they reuse this information recycle it
and then this mission gets to the
official level
and this informational nonsense always
circulates
to create a feeling of a new hybrid
warfare
and informational type and use of
vaccines as a tool aggressive actions by
russia
the fact that we don't have a vaccine
then they use all this uh
the fact these facts to prove that
we use it as a means of war
and then at the same time to say that
when we don't have a vaccine in the
interior
we have nothing to vaccinate our
population with
i think that the representative of the
eu
don't really understand the gravitative
situation and
[Music]
use this nonsensical statements
and we'll use them further
currently all manufacturers of
anti-covet
vaccines
don't use all many russian manufacturers
of vaccines
don't use this
political tools and but try
to assure ensure access
to the vaccine universal access
they try to promulgate the specs in all
regions we don't
impose our will onto anyone we're not
we're not forcing anyone to do anything
but we are
still trying to perform an open
interaction
we are ready to ship our vex into all
interested states
of excellence is highly effective and
safe i would like to
unders underline once again
please stop consulting
our colleagues from the foreign offices
please stop consulting following blogs
and
stop covering the inability to solve
internal problems
by uh russia's aggressive actions please
stop using
lies and fake news to justify
to your own people why you cannot
handle this common challenge
why do you use all the range of
inadmissible methods
ranging from propaganda and deformations
to
flagrant political oppressions and
influence
to in one way another
avoid responsibility for your failures
in many directions we are convinced
that the resolution of the covenant 19
pandemic it's impossible
and like impossible without reuniting
efforts of all the members of the
national community
as we said on numerous occasions
the key priority is the vaccination
of the entire population for the public
good
this is not just the opinion of our
specialists
but also its opinion is
based on an analysis by
international organizations engaging in
health sphere
and we think it's highly important that
people despite the imposed
propaganda in many countries
ask the governments directly addressing
russia with a request
to ship them the vaccine
and improve relations regarding this
supply and manufacture of the vex and
russian vaccines
the public of the european union doesn't
like the statement of the european
commission bureaucracies they don't like
the attempts to politicize
everything that's connected to the topic
of the vaccine the
attempts to stall the vaccine and i see
this through the materials in the
internet in the media
countries that haven't yet shipped
specifically vaccine
the public in these countries just
demand their governments
to give them access to vaccines
including the russian one
and stop the politicizing of this
question
it was a very good phrase in one of the
articles i read
they said that the real science has no
national borders
it is used
peace there shouldn't be borders in this
case
there shouldn't be any artificial
borders furthermore
and i'm ready to answer your next
question
yes please afghanistan
agency i have three questions first
question
how would you comment statement of the
us representative of an impossibility to
withdraw troops from afghanistan
may 1st as was arranged on
during doka negotiations
i understand that the topic is very
troubling
and connected to the lives of ordinary
citizens but it's impossible to
not to be ironic about the situation
when you're talking about the promises
of united states
to withdraw u.s troops and i would like
to see which year which aided were
planning to withdraw the troops
because they were
they were stating
new dates to wither their troops every
year they have new promises every year
they are publishing new plans
once again we heard the statement
regarding
the intention to complete it
by may first this year the technical
difficulties
regarding the american withdrawal are
just nothing but slyness
the dates have been arranged more than a
year ago when you understand that stem
was
pretty enough to complete
all necessary preparations and think
that the true motive
of pro longing the withdrawal
is the fear for the fate of current
of afghanistan which despite 20 years of
active military technical cooperation
the part of nato are still unable to
independently solve their task in the
security domain
general clock the head of special
operations united states
said and i quote
he was presenting in the senate
recently in this he cited the critical
dependency of afghanistan on
the nato assistance
we would like to point your attention
that
this topic was
discussed
by singular during his holiday club
session the text is on the website
and he said that their deployment is
prolonged indefinitely there will be no
date for withdrawal
mr larov said that they went back on
their word
they just first made a promise then
changed the decision
they're just exploiting the hydrocarbon
resources in afghanistan
syria for example
and blocking dialogue between kurds and
damascus and syria
to prevent it from happening and at the
same time they're saying that
isis is being resurgent in the
territories out of
reach of the syrian government
you understand the principal point i'm
making
and just if you allow me i have the
second question
participate russia's position on the
proposal
of afghanistan's president to reach
the national reconciliation through
the organization of early elections in
afghanistan under the control of
international community we believe that
this
question should first be referred to the
taliban
because we proceed from the afghan-led
and afghan-owned peace process
we will accept any decision that will be
acceptable for both
warring parties as far as we know
the taliban has rejected the kabul's
initiative
by saying that previous elections
were accompanied with the scandals and
has put
the country on the brink of the crisis
and the last question
[Music]
what does russia expect from the talks
of the istanbul format in afghanistan
and who is going to take part there i
think it's
too early to talk about the
establishment of a new format because
we're talking about
a single event to support the talks in
doha
with the participation of certain
regional and international
partners of afghanistan as well as
high-ranking delegations of kabul and
the taliban
we will welcome any initiatives that
will ensure
the achievement of peace in afghanistan
but still
the details of turkey are not quite
clear
we don't know about the participants
the data the format and other questions
and
russia will be ready to
determine representation once we receive
all the details
do you have any more questions
is not here no okay
since there are no questions farewell
see you next time
have a good day and stay safe
so
um
you